nigeria's central bank is absolutely
lost their minds i love nigeria i love
nigerians i went to nigeria a couple
years ago and in nigeria the two things
that stuck out to me is one the country
of i think 200 million people or so is
growing at an incredible rate it is
estimated that nigeria will be larger on
a population basis than the united
states by the year 2050. it's a very
young population it's a very fast
growing population and there is great
internet penetration in the country
there are a ton of digital natives that
are growing up in nigeria they
understand the internet they understand
smartphones and they are trying to use
the internet to build a better life very
similar to india what we are watching is
that the nigerian population continues
to push that country forward and to make
a better life for themselves using the
internet and using technology now one of
the things that they want is bitcoin we
have seen that nigeria is one of the
most popular countries in the world on a
per capita basis for bitcoin ownership
and usage we've also seen an explosion
of interest in peer-to-peer exchanges
and also with mining after nigeria
banned bitcoin ownership it doesn't
matter the people want it the people
need it the local currency the naira
continues to suffer and in some cases
there is 15 plus percent inflation in
nigeria so if you have a macro
environment that is pushing people out
of the local currency they're trying to
find another asset and then along comes
a digital currency that is decentralized
that can't be debased it can't be
censored and you don't need permission
to buy it or to use it from anyone else
of course it's going to become
attractive if your entire population or
a very big portion of your population
are young people who are technology
savvy but nigeria
is not going to allow that to just
happen overnight the nigerian central
bank is launching a central bank digital
currency they call it the e naira very
clever electronic naira
now the e naira is not meant to replace
the existing currency it is meant to
complement their physical currency and
specifically not to replace it
you can use it with basically two
separate applications they have built an
e-nira speed wallet and they have built
an e-nira merchant wallet so they have
literally built something for consumers
and they have built a piece of
technology for merchants the idea is to
take the central bank currency not
change the monetary policy in any way
and simply to upgrade the technology
where most of it is in physical form and
there's a very high percent of people
who are unbanked and now start to bring
them into the digital world the exact
same monetary policy but the technology
ends up being different now there are
over
500 million inira about 1.2 million
already minted 200 million have been
issued to financial institutions and 33
banks 2 000 customers and 120 merchants
had already registered successfully with
the platform so when you start to look
at this it is very clear that there is a
possibility that you are going to get
the incumbents to start to adopt this
but the question always becomes when you
start to hand digital wallets to
individuals where will they store their
wealth i personally believe that one of
the things that people are drastically
underestimating
is that as the central bank digital
currencies come online
all of these countries are going to go
and they're going to do massive
campaigns they're going to tell people
go get a digital wallet go get a digital
wallet here we'll give you a digital
wallet we'll pay you to get a digital
wallet but when you digitize every
currency in the world whether it's the
naira the dollar the euro the yen or the
peso every single currency will be
digital and when those currencies are
all digital there is no competition at a
technology layer there is no i use the e
naira because it's digital and i can't
use the dollar because i can only get
physical dollars everything is digital
so the competition moves from a
technology competition up to a monetary
policy competition and that monetary
policy competition every single fiat
currency in the world is exactly the
same on a relative basis they have
little differences in their interest
rates or in their contraction or
expansion of their money supplies
but from a macro standpoint every fiat
currency is the exact same there's an
unlimited supply there's a small group
of people who determine the monetary
policy and there is no predict uh
predictability to it you don't know
what's going to happen in the future and
there is very little to any transparency
around the monetary policy and the
actual execution of the currency's
specific aspects
bitcoin is 180 degree difference
it's a finite supply there will only
ever be 21 million it's completely
transparent you know everything that
happens i can go back to january 3rd
2009 and show you every single bitcoin
that has been created who has held it
all the way up till today exactly how
many bitcoin are coming into the supply
today everything everything is
transparent and the monetary policy ends
up being 100 predictable you can know it
with certainty because it's written in a
code and no one person can change it
and so ultimately bitcoin is 180 degree
difference now the big bet that i think
people are willing to take
is that ultimately for a global store of
value forget a medium of exchange permit
for a store of value
you have one asset that is going to be
depreciated over time it actually is
easier to use today in terms of a medium
of exchange for the moment
but from a global store value standpoint
if the fiat currencies are going to
continue to be devalued at a historic
pace all around the world
people especially in places like nigeria
that are experiencing high levels of
inflation they're going to choose
something that can't be debased
something that they can store their
wealth in and hold it for generations
and pass it on to their kids or their
grandkids
that ultimately is what we're watching
here so if we go ahead and we look at
this map
you can see on this map what is the
popularity on a global basis you can see
that there are 90 countries currency
unions that are being tracked and so you
can see this is all the central bank
digital currencies and right there smack
dab hello nigeria they are one of them
and so ultimately i do not think that
these central bank digital currencies
will end up over a long period of time
being a drastic net positive to
individuals they drastically increase
financial surveillance and they increase
all sorts of nasty stuff that we've
never thought about before
things like personalized monetary policy
everything in your life is personalized
your news feed is personalized to you
your search results are personalized to
you the music you listen to is
personalized to you when you ask google
maps to go somewhere it's personalized
to you everything in your life that you
interact with with a keyboard or a
screen is personalized
the one digital thing that you interact
with though that is not yet personalized
is your money and so there will be a day
where central banks start to say
joe
you deserve a higher inflation rate
than pomp
john you deserve a lower interest rate
than pomp how they will underwrite it
how they will create it nobody yet knows
but it's scary to think because that
ends up being the ultimate
discrimination
on top of that you then add in things
like expiration dates to the money we
see here in the united states with ebt
cards that they actually only allow you
to spend it on certain things and you
only have a specific amount of time to
spend it we've also seen in places like
china they have actually looked at
things like stimulus checks having an
expiration date
nasty nasty stuff that previously wasn't
possible
but when you give people technology and
new capabilities
you can hope and cross your fingers that
they won't use it
to the detriment of the people
or you can simply put yourself in a
position
where regardless of what they do you're
protected i think that's ultimately what
we're gonna watch happen in nigeria